un terrain russe on continue d'afficher
une posture conquérante hier lors d'un
forum économique tournée vers l'asie
vladimir poutine a pris la parole
fustigeant l'attitude des occidentaux
menaçant même de suspendre les
livraisons d'hydrocarbures aux européens
en réponse à la proposition du gel des
prix du gaz armée charrier bonjour un
temps fort que vous avez suivi pour nous
pas nos onze de fléchissement dans les
les interventions les discours de
vladimir poutine qui affichent de plus
en plus sa volonté de créer ce nouveau
bloc à l'est oui clairement aujourd'hui
il se positionne sur un futur en partant
du principe que la guerre en ukraine et
quelque chose acté alors c'est pas
toujours appelé une guerre ça s'appelle
toujours une opération spéciale mais
pour lui le travail continue à se faire
sur le terrain avec son artillerie
village par village on sait pas
exactement ce qui est en train de se
passer avec la contre-offensive
ukrainienne s'est tassée au parc côté
ukrainien c'est assez opaque aussi côté
russe donc dans ce flou il existe
effectivement une capacité pour lui
d'avancer ses pions en disant on
récupère du terrain et on récupère du
terrain on peut le validé puisque de
toute manière c'est pour ça que son
parti veut faire un référendum sur place
en ukraine veut asseoir ses pions et
dire à partir du mans données ou la
population aura validé l'appartenance à
la russie dans ces cas là ce sera
beaucoup plus compliqué avec des nuances
qui de pouvoir négocier un nom à dire
une reconquête du territoire est ce que
la population le fera ne le fera pas il
ya de toute manière des transferts qui
ont été faits aussi et il ya une partie
de la population qui se battaient
justement parce qu'elle voulait être
rattachés à la russie donc tout ça lui
donne un capital quand on est dans ces
régions du dombass et c'est vrai que à
partir du moment donné où il a souvent
une légitimité par cette voie là du coup
il est d'autant plus en capacité de les
négocier avec les pays de l'asie en
disant regardez j'ai aujourd'hui une
rupture de contrat moral militaire et
économique avec le monde occidental
venez travailler avec moi dans une
nouvelle ère qui sera plus asiatique et
sur lequel dans ces cas-là on
abandonnera le dollar qui nous permet
d'avoir des sanctions donc si on
travaille en roubles ouf
maintenant on sera hors des risques à
américain et côté occidentaux justement
aujourd'hui on va parler soutien aux
capacités militaires craignent n les
ministres de la défense des pays alliés
ont tous rendez-vous aujourd'hui en
allemagne oui sur la base de ramstein
qui est la base américaine donc là
encore c'est un signal fort c'est un
signal militaire il faut effectivement
avoir là aussi une j'allais dire plus
grande clarté sur ce qui est en train de
se passer du côté ukrainien
parce que du coup il faut continuer à
pouvoir les armes et il faut continuer à
pouvoir leur donner une capacité de se
défendre et il faut évidemment dans ces
cas là à voir un côté pratique alors
qu'est ce qu'on est capable de fournir
aux ukrainiens aujourd'hui le problème
c'est ça c'est qu'il faut relancer une
industrie de la défense qui si elle doit
fournir des munitions ou des armements
va le faire avec un certain temps de
décalage or aujourd'hui les ukrainiens
en ont besoin là tout de suite ils sont
sur le principe maintenant avec la
russie ni les européens ni les
américains ne veulent taper dans les
stocks stratégiques des pays donc dans
ces conditions c'est plus complexe on
parle de leur donner des armes qui sont
adaptés à l'hiver ce le message
américain parce qu'on va rentrer
effectivement dans cette zone hivernale
mais ce qu'on va attendre aussi des
américains là c'est aussi d'avoir un
autre discussion parce que face à ceux
narratif fort de vladimir poutine qui ne
raisonnent peut-être pas beaucoup en
europe qui peuvent fonctionner dans
d'autres pays il y a aussi la
température des populations européennes
qui sont quand même soumise à une
inflation grandissante qui voit
effectivement des risques énergétiques
et qui donc dans ces cas là ont aussi
besoin de comprendre quelles sont les
positions des uns et des autres merci
beaucoup m